- I actually think that
winters in LA are really bad,
because the houses aren't insulated,
so at night I have to
wear sweatpants to bed.
Californians Try to Figure
Out Winter Survival Hacks.
What was your harshest California winter?
- The harshest winter
I've ever experienced
is a sweatshirt, maybe a jacket.
- It's hailed a few times.
- I think one time it rained.
- It's never bad, I mean
clearly, it's 79 degrees
outside right now, and
I'm wearing a sweater,
because I'm kind of cold.
- The first time I saw snow fall in person
was a few years ago in
Iceland, of all places.
- I know people are going
to be like, oh Californians
can't handle the cold weather.
Whatever.
- I can't handle the cold weather.
Road Salt.
- Hell yeah, I know what this is!
- Salt.
- That's (bleep) salt.
- I mean, I know you throw
this on icy stuff, 'cause
I've seen Home Alone, and
there's the weird, like salt guy.
- This helps you so you don't
slip around, break your neck.
- My hand's not going anywhere.
- This could be some nice traction.
- It makes the snow melt.
- Yeah.
- So it doesn't stay on the road.
- You shovel the snow.
- You shovel the snow,
and then you put this on
the ice, and it melts it.
- And you just leave it for how long?
- Shrinks the snow up, got it.
- [Man] Your shoes get ruined.
- Your shoes get ruined?
That's not okay.
- Did you eat it? (laughs)
- Do you ever use this for cooking?
- Ew.
- This goes on the floor!
Tire Chains.
- I have no idea what this could be.
- This just looks like a death trap.
- Is this for your sled?
- Snow chains, right?
- Or it's, like, a really cool ladder.
- These are for tires.
- Yeah, yeah, they're the snow chains.
That's an easy one.
- I assumed they were
chain chains, like, chains.
- Yeah, me too.
- These are like what rappers wear.
- [Man] Well, there are two chains there.
- Two chains.
- It's like, how has
technology not gotten better,
where you don't have to use these?
- I mean, I have no idea how to use this.
- This seems like a prehistoric
type of thing, like...
- You could probably tear up
the road with these things,
if you're not careful.
- Like middle ages, like for your horses.
- It's just a hassle,
that's just what it is.
- Be careful out there, cold people.
Hand Warmers.
- East coast, blow on your hands.
You're not going to put your
hands in fancy little pouches.
- Or if I'm tired, just put a couple
on my eyes.
- Oh, on your face.
- Yeah.
- Oh that...
- That feels great.
- It's not working for me.
- I feel it!
Feel this.
- Oh (bleep), yours is warm.
How come mine's cold?
- Because you didn't
expose it to the air.
- Oh, oh, okay, professional
(bleep) Californian.
- If I had these on the east
coast, I would just be like
heating them up and
then, like, throwing them
in the snow so that it melts, cause I...
- Moses, you've felt cold, you don't know.
KItty Litter.
- Hold up.
- So, is this a joke?
- Cats pee and poop in this.
- We have kitty litter also.
- We know what kitty litter
is, in sunny California
- We have this.
- We have cats.
- Uh, uh...
- Uh...
- Why would you also throw
cat litter on the snow?
- Odor control!
- Maybe you got some smelly snow.
- Maybe your cat wants to
take a dump in the wilderness.
- That's kitty litter, all right.
- Oh, it's strong smelling.
- Maybe when you don't
have enough money for that
fancy salt you were
throwing around earlier,
you gotta get this kitty litter going.
- Let's see how traction-y it is.
Kitty litter is used to
create traction for tires
when a car is stuck in the snow.
- This is not a good choice.
I don't think you guys are, I don't...
I think you should reevaluate.
- So, do people actually,
like, have this in their trunk?
- No, they don't.
- [Man] Yeah.
- [Man] Yes, they do.
I don't believe you, I feel
like you're (bleep) with us.
- Oh, it's a thing, okay.
- You guys must all have
a lot of cats as well.
Could you survive a real winter?
- Uhhhhh..
- No.
(laughs)
Oh my god.
- Below zero?
No, what, no.
- I can't even handle lukewarm weather.
- Probably like 15 minutes.
- I could never survive
if my car was stuck.
I would call AAA.
- [Man] What if AAA couldn’t get to you?
AAA can't get to, what?
- I mean, I would like to
think that I would do okay
in, like, Chicago, but
I'm pretty sure people
are going to laugh at me
once they see this video.
- You should come stay with us
in California.
- Sunny California.
- It's really nice, look behind us.
I'm so sorry.